real seekers and history lovers could
soon get front-row seats two treasures
even historical remains deep under the
sea our own David beg now has that story
far from the frigid North Atlantic
waters that claim the Titanic a 2019
mission to reach the ill-fated ocean
liner reached a major milestone this
week in the Bahamas four months
ocean gates team of scientists and
explorers have been depth testing their
privately built man's submersible it's
called Titan and it's off the coast of
Abaco island they needed a sub to reach
13,000 feet that is the necessary depth
to reach the Titanic's wreck site on
Monday Ocean gate founder Stockton rush
got there becoming only the second
person ever to reach that depth solo the
other person was Titanic director James
Cameron I was so busy in the sub when I
got down there that I didn't appreciate
it until I started to come back up and
as I came to the surface and realized
that it accomplished this this amazing
thing it was just a great moment of joy
the 10-ton sub capable of carrying five
people launches from a specially built
platform that was designed to sink below
the waves releasing titan into deeper
waters I can't express what that has
meant to me and what it means to to
imagine the great things we're gonna
explore and find in the ocean in the
years to come the achievement not only
opens up 50 percent of the ocean to
private manned exploration it also paves
the way for annual survey expeditions to
Titanic's final resting place to map the
wreck and create a detailed 3d model of
the ship and its debris field
researchers and explorers will be able
to join gates expeditions for a fee
$100,000 that's the inflation-adjusted
price of a first-class ticket in 1912
we expect to survive a Titanic over many
years it's a gigantic site and we want
to collect as much data as possible
before it decays into the ocean the
first of ocean gates scheduled
expeditions to the Titanic run from June
to August of 2019 for CBS this morning
Saturday I'm David Beck no
who's buying a ticket that's so exciting
what they're doing I would love to go
really yeah would you just need $100,000
yeah it's all so good oh oh well I'll
stay out here